48 hours uncovered chilling new details
in the murder of a Manhattan millionaire
the case took investigators more than
two decades to solve back in 1996
entrepreneur Howard Pihl Marv was
stabbed to death in the headquarters of
his businesses police suspected his wife
Rosalyn killed him with the help of her
brother Evan Wald but for more than 20
years prosecutors did not think they had
enough evidence to pursue charges 48
hours correspondent Richard Schlesinger
spoke to the victim's father and
stepmother for their first network
television interviews it was Friday
morning March 22nd 1996 when Howard pill
Mars body was found in a pool of blood
on his office floor he had been stabbed
repeatedly former NYPD commander Rodger
Perino a good percentage of the stab
wounds on the back were all postmortem
after he was dead yeah after is that
this is I want to make sure you're dead
absolutely that completely and utterly
dead who could have done this to Howard
who would want to kill my son his father
Frank and stepmother Carol he was dead
over 40 times it had to be somebody who
he knew that that hated him so much it
looked like Howard and his wife Rosalyn
were living really well they had a young
son and Howard was expanding the
family's office supply business selling
high-end coffee Starbucks before
Starbucks was right Starbucks that's
right Frank Pihl Marv suspected Rosslyn
had something to do with Howard's death
police learned she was in trouble with a
former employer
she had embezzled a large sum of money
and there were one or two surprises
about Roslin's brother Evan Wald when
detectives interviewed him he had cuts
on his left hand he said he got them
when he was working at Howard's coffee
business did they look suspicious to you
given that this was a stabbing so the
cuts don't look suspicious the
individual starts looking suspicious it
was beginning to look like Howard's
murder could be a family affair but
police did not make an arrest
years went by they never found the
weapon and they never had a witness but
after two decades the family's nanny
finally revealed what she knew about the
night of the murder and that's when
everything changed
and Richard joins us now Richard
fantastic characters yeah yeah really
and only in New York and the nanny's
interesting too what role did she play
she played a key role yeah and the
interesting thing was back to when this
happened she was very young she was just
out of college and the theory is she was
just afraid to talk to the police yeah
well she's older now and she's been
thinking about this all these years
she's talking now and she's turned the
case why did it take so long with you
well you know that was my question
because they had a lot of evidence but
the prosecutors were afraid you know
prosecutors go for beyond a reasonable
doubt and they were afraid that there
were alternate explanations for some of
this evidence and the a jury would
wouldn't convict coffey alibi yeah I'll
be shot thank you very much thank you
you can see Richards report who wanted
howard pill Mar Dead that's tomorrow
night at 10:00 9:00 central right here
on CBS